The upcoming Disney+ series The Mandalorian
takes place during an unexplored time period
in the Star Wars universe.
It's set five years after Return of the Jedi,
and will serve as a bridge between that film
and The Force Awakens.
Since the time gap that separates those two
films is 30 years, there are bound to be plenty
of revelations mixed into The Mandalorian.
And apparently, fans won't have to wait long
to experience at least one of them: according
to The New York Times, The Mandalorian's very
first episode contains a major spoiler.
The Times didn't reveal what the spoiler is,
but it did say this in a throwaway line tucked
in a lengthy article about the impending November
12 launch of Disney+:
"The Mandalorian, which contains a dramatic
Star Wars universe spoiler in the first episode
and will be available the moment Disney Plus
starts, has been as heavily promoted as a
traditional feature film, with billboards,
30-second television commercials, radio spots
and digital ads."
The show's time frame offers up some tantalizing
possibilities about the bombshell spoiler
that awaits.
By taking place between the fall of the Empire
and the rise of the First Order, The Mandalorian
is primed to show how the First Order came
to be.
As show creator Jon Favreau told Entertainment
Weekly,
"What could happen in the 30 years between
celebrating the defeat of the Empire and then
the First Order?
You come in on Episode VII, [the First Order
are] not just starting out.
So somehow, things weren't necessarily managed
as well as they could have been if [the galaxy]
ended up in hot water again like that."
Contrary to the rumors that swirled when the
series was first announced, according to the
show's creators, The Mandalorian is not about
Boba Fett.
Lead actor Pedro Pascal plays an as-yet unnamed
Mandalorian bounty hunter who operates in
the seedy outer rim of the galaxy.
Carl Weathers portrays Greef Carga, the head
of a bounty hunting guild and an occasional
ally of the Mandalorian, while Giancarlo Esposito
plays a former Imperial Governor named Moff
Gideon.
Werner Herzog's character is a crime boss,
Taika Waititi voices droid IG-11, and Gina
Carano plays ex-Rebel Shock Trooper and current
mercenary Cara Dune.
They, too, will cross paths with the Mandalorian
in their own unique ways.
Perhaps the most obvious spoiler is that the
series' crew has been bamboozling us all along,
and the show really is about Boba Fett or
someone related to him.
"The gloved, Mandalorian armor gauntlet of
Boba Fett grabs onto the sand outside of the
Sarlacc pit..."
But it's hard to see the universe-wide implications
of that, despite some fans' desire to see
it.
"...and we realize that he survived his fall
during the battle at Jabba's Palace ship."
Maybe the first episode of The Mandalorian
could offer a spoiler that helps set up The
Rise of Skywalker.
The series premieres on November 12, and Star
Wars Episode IX opens in theaters December
20.
That gives fans plenty of time to catch The
Mandalorian before watching the film, so if
the series, say, reveals how Emperor Palpatine
survived the destruction of the second Death
Star, fans would be extremely motivated to
pony up for a full Disney+ subscription to
watch the show before seeing the movie.
Disney has already hinted at seeding its upcoming
MCU offerings on Disney+ with story beats
that will affect later films.
Namely, the streaming series WandaVision is
set to tie into the film Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness.
Hey, wait a minute…
"If he holds the Reality Gem, that means he
can jump from different realities.
This will be our link to the Marvel Universe
from the Star Wars universe!"
Eh, probably not.
The other big possibility is renewed canon
from the old Expanded Universe.
Some fans think Mara Jade, Luke Skywalker's
wife in the EU, may be in The Mandalorian,
and Favreau didn't exactly deny it when asked
about it.
He told EW in September 2019,
"I don't want to talk about anything that
might be fun for people to discover [...] Part
of what's fun to see if we could merge the
worlds of the original trilogy, the prequels,
the sequels, The Clone Wars, and what's been
considered canon up to this point and what's
been considered part of Legends.
I think this show offers an opportunity to
bring in all those elements."
The only way to know for certain what this
big Star Wars spoiler truly is would be to
tune into the debut episode of The Mandalorian,
hitting Disney+ on November 12.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.